You don't have any power on the one
hand. If you're a career changer, maybe
we're a bit too pragmatic,
which is difficult in politics, so
right now the topics that we're
all discussing in Germany are
causing a certain degree of dissatisfaction, which I actually feel very strongly about
I think it's a shame because we have a great country, it's
because the topics
we just discussed focus on
a few topics, clear communication also
explain explain what I'm doing
um and the whole over-focusing on
the important topics for Germany that's
exactly not what's happening right now and  You
ask yourself the question why not because
you are always
dependent on this willingness to compromise, which is
now the case with budget issues and in
which most politicians I have
met are neither
willing nor able to make clear announcements